stellt euch vor ihr sitzt ruhig in einem
Restaurant oder Café und plötzlich hört
ihr nur ein paar Meter entfernt Schüsse
fallen wahrscheinlich würdet ihr dann
lieber aufs leckere Essen verzichten und
mit leerem Magen schnell die Flucht
ergreifen nicht wahr nun leider sind
solche Situationen in vielen
zentralamerikanischen Städten keine
Seltenheit Städte die bekannt sind für
ihre unzulänglichen Sicherheitsmaßnahmen
[Musik]
im Jahr 2022 befanden sich 42 der 50
gewalttätigsten Städte der Welt in
Lateinamerika zwei davon in Honduras
eine in Guatemala und eine in El
Salvador allein im Jahr 2017 wurden im
Mittelamerika im ersten 14.500
Tötungsdelikte registriert die
überwiegende Mehrzahl mehr als 90% davon
ereigneten sich in drei Ländern die als
das nördliche Dreieck bekannt sind er
ist Salvador und Duras und Guatemala im
Vergleich während sich die
Tötungsdelikte in Westeuropa Japan oder
dem Nahen Osten im Jahr 2019 auf einen
pro 100.000 Einwohner beliefen waren es
in Lateinamerika
Venezuela Honduras Guatemala und Mexiko
oftmals über 30 in El Salvador sogar 55
pro 100 000 Einwohner das ist nahezu das
50-fache und das ist schon gelinde
gesagt erschreckend warum also ist die
Gewalt in ausgerechnet diesen Teil der
Welt so verbreitet was beeinflusst diese
hohen verbrechensraten war
Zentralamerika schon immer eine
gewalttätige Region nun lasst es uns
herausfinden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
lasst uns mit einer kleinen Frage an
euch beginnen ist euch jemals
aufgefallen die bemerkenswert die Karte
des gesamten amerikanischen Kontinents
aussieht schaut man sie sich nämlich
genauer an sieht man schnell das
Mittelamerika quasi eine Brücke zwischen
Südamerika und Nordamerika bildet und
das nicht nur metaphorisch sondern im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes diese
geographische Konstellation hat
Konsequenzen
die Tatsache das Zentralamerika als
Brücke fungiert hat es zur größten
illegalen Transitstrecke der Welt
gemacht und zwar für in Südamerika
produzierte illegale Güter die in
Nordamerika nachgefragt werden wir
sprechen hauptsächlich über Kokain nicht
weniger als 90% des gesamten Kokains das
in die USA dem weltweit größten Markt
für diese Droge gelangt geht über
Zentralamerika aber glaubt nicht dass
dies die einzige illegale Aktivität ist
die es dort gibt ganz und gar nicht der
Menschenhandel der Handel mit illegalen
Einwanderern und Minderjährigen Punkt
ebenfalls in dieser Region am Ende
dieses Videos werdet ihr genau verstehen
wie das alles die Drogen die Armut das
Elend den Menschenhandel und Migration
miteinander zusammenhängen und wie ihr
euch bereits jetzt vorstellen könnt
gehen all diese Aktivitäten Hand in Hand
mit organisierter Kriminalität
[Musik]
gewaltige kriminelle Organisationen die
all diese Geschäfte kontrollieren
verwalten und gegeneinander um die
Vorherrschaft kämpfen wir sprechen von
einer riesigen Industrie und zwar eine
hochgradig strukturierten mit Managern
Verwaltern Anwälten Unternehmensberatern
mit Diversifizierung Anlagestrategien
und so weiter und so fort eine Industrie
die ihre Präsenz in Zentralamerika
zunehmend vorantreibt sieht euch einfach
mal folgendes an Untersuchungen zur
Folge verlagern mexikanische Kartellen
90 Prozent ihrer Aktivitäten nach
zentral Amerika der zunehmende Druck des
Staates in Mexiko in den letzten Jahren
hat dazu geführt dass ich diese Art der
Mafia in Ländern mit schwächeren und
weniger wachsamen Regierungen
niederlassen will und wisst ihr was die
Wahrheit ist dass diese Gruppen diese
Konzerne der makrokriminalität ist
bereits geschafft haben einen Großteil
Zentralamerikas einzunehmen
[Musik]
Mexiko Zentralamerikas
kriminalitätsexporteur Numero Uno
Mexiko oder besser gesagt die
mexikanischen Kartelle entwickeln sich
langsam zu den Anführern den größten und
dominanten Akteuren des narcobusiness in
ganz Laterne Amerika natürlich
konkurrieren sie schon seit geraumer
Zeit mit kolumbianischen Banden
[Musik]
aber die mexikanischen Kartelle
kontrollieren bereits die Mehrzahl der
Hauptrouten für den Transport illegaler
waren und das bedeutet so ziemlich die
Kontrolle über ganz Mittelamerika
testen wir uns einmal eine Sekunde lang
in die Lage dieser großen Bosse stellt
euch vor dass ihr einer von ihnen seid
was wäre der schnellste Weg um das
zentralamerikanische Territorium zu
kontrollieren wie kann man sich in
dieser Region breit machen und sie
beherrschen
[Musik]
ganz genau eine gute Option wäre es
Bündnisse mit den Einheimischen
kriminellengruppen einzugehen mit denen
die vorher schon da waren Gruppen die
über die nötige Infrastruktur Kontakte
und Kenntnis über das Gebiet verfügen
wir sprechen von Gruppen die nur eine
einzige Philosophie haben immer mit
genau hier in zusammenzuarbeiten die
ihnen zum größten Batzen Geld verhelfen
dies ist nicht überraschend wir alle
kennen die Macht des Dollars
aber wie und warum genau wurde
Mittelamerika Angriffsziel für die
Ausbeutung durch die mexikanischen
Drogenhändler nun um das zu verstehen
müssen wir bis in die 90er Jahre
zurückgehen
[Musik]
der entscheidende Zeitraum in dem sich
die Machtverhältnisse verschoben haben
ereignete sich zwischen 1991 und 93 als
das Kartell von Medellin seine größte
Niederlage erlebt der Sturz von Pablo
escobara als jenen der einflussreichsten
Bosse des Kartells bedeutet sozusagen
den Verlust des enormen Einflusses und
er macht die sie sich in Mittelamerika
bisher erkämpft hatten und diese dank
ihrer Bündnisse mit lokalen Gruppen die
direkt für sie arbeiteten gewinnen
konnten dieses große Zeitfenster nutzten
die mexikanischen Banken um nach
Mittelamerika zu stürmen mit dem Ziel
diese wichtige Brücke vollständig zu
kontrollieren welche die
Produktionszentren mit den Konsumenten
verbindet einige von euch denken jetzt
sicher aber Moment mal es gibt doch
sicher mehrere Kartelle in Mexiko ist
das nicht problematisch und die Antwort
lautet ja in der Tat als die Mexikaner
nach Mittelamerika kam wurde das Gebiet
zu einer Art Schlachtfeld für die
verschiedenen mexikanischen Kartelle die
um die Kontrolle der Transportwege
kämpften und genau das ist einer der
Gründe dafür warum die Gewalt in
Mittelamerika drastisch Zunahmen bis
schließlich jedes Kartell seine claims
das heißt sein Eigen Territorium und
seine nischengebiete wenn man so will
abgesteckt hatte man könnte sagen dass
mexikanische Kartelle zu einem der
zentralsten Exporteure von Gewalten
Kriminalität für ihre südlichen Nachbarn
wurden schaut euch beispielsweise und
Duras an
[Musik]
die drastische Zunahme der Kriminalität
in diesen Jahren erklärt sich zu einem
großen Teil aus den Machtkämpfen
zwischen mexikanischen Kartellen und
lokalen Gruppen um einflusskontrolle und
macht über Drogengeschäfte der fallhund
Duras wo Korruption einen ganzen Staat
zerstört hat ist übrigens derart
abschreckend dass der sogar ein eigenes
Video darüber gedreht haben dass ich
euch in der Beschreibung unter diesem
Video verlinken werde damit ihr es euch
nachher ansehen könnt aber lasst uns die
Zahlen nun beiseite legen konzentrieren
wir uns lieber auf die Straße denn die
Frage ist wie genau wirken sich all
diese Kämpfe zwischen Kartellen und
zentralamerikanischen kriminellen
Gruppen auf die Sicherheit der
gewöhnlichen Bürger aus aufgepasst
wenn Gewalt keinen Feind findet
wir haben bereits erwähnt dass das
zentralamerikanische nördliche Dreieck
die höchsten Kriminalitätsraten der Welt
aufweist deshalb nur die zentrale Frage
gibt es eine Lösung was braucht die
Region um sozialen Friedens soziale Ruhe
zu finden nun die Wahrheit ist dieses
Ziel ist sehr schwer zu erreichen schaut
euch mal folgendes an der Bruder des
honduranischen Präsidenten des
Drogenhandels für schuldig befunden
Honduras Präsident Werte Verschwörung
mit der Drogenmafia beschuldigt die
Staatsanwaltschaft geht davon aus dass
die drogenprofile zu Unterstützung der
Wahl des honduranischen Präsidenten Juan
Orlando Hernandez im Jahr 2013 verwendet
wurden ehemaliger Präsident von
zwei Jahren Haft wegen Bestechung
verurteilt angesichts eines derartigen
Ausmaßes an Korruption
institutionalisierten Drogenhandel und
anderen verachtenswerten Handlungen wer
würde sich da noch der
Verbrechensbekämpfung Erbarmen und seine
Stimme erheben vor allem wenn das
Verbrechen das Gesetz ist wenn die
höchsten Machtsphären Mittelamerikas so
enge Verbindungen zu den großen
Verbrechern haben wie in aller Welt will
man sie dann bekämpfen
[Musik]
nun grundsätzlich ist dies kein Ding der
Unmöglichkeit in erster Linie geht es
aber um die Anreize die geboten werden
denn wer will schon die ganz töten
welche die goldenen Eier legt trotz
dieser harten Realität muss darauf
hingewiesen werden dass in den letzten
Jahren ein allmählicher Rückgang der
nordraten in Mittelamerika zu
verzeichnen ist und dies hat vielen
Politikern den Mut gegeben sich zu
erheben werfen wir mal einen Blick auf
El Salvador
dort gab es beispielsweise im Jahr 2018
15% weniger Tötungsdelikte als im
Vorjahr dennoch war die Zeit immer noch
sehr hoch 3340 Mordfälle in einem Jahr
in einem Land mit weniger als
sechseinhalb Millionen Einwohnern war
lange das Land mit der höchsten nordrate
in der gefährlichsten Region auf diesem
Planeten man könnte also sagen das
gefährlichste Land der Welt wenn man
sich die Geschichte des Landes ansieht
sieht man dass die Wurzeln der Gewalt
durchaus weiter zurückreichen und zwar
schon lange bevor die mexikanische Karte
in Zentralamerika überhaupt Fuß gefasst
haben wir haben bereits in früheren
Videos hier auf visualpolitik über sie
berichtet die Mara sind gefährliche
kriminelle Banken viele von ihnen mit
Sitz in Los Angeles die sich
hauptsächlich dem Drogen und
Waffenhandel der Geldwäsche dem Handel
mit dem Migranten und der Prostitution
verschrieben haben seit den 1960er
Jahren sind sie eine der größten
Herausforderungen die es in puncto
Sicherheit zu bewältigen gibt
während der Zeit des Kalten Kriegs in
den 70ern 80er Jahren ging die Länder
Mittelamerikas durch eine Phase schwerer
Bürger welche oft auch
Stellvertreterkriege zwischen den USA
und das Sowjetunion bzw kubawaren die
zahlreichen Interventionen der USA
mitsamt der Installierung brutaler
kuntas heiße die Desintegration der
Gesellschaft noch weiter an
Familienstrukturen zerbrachen und die
Menschen oftmals verweiste Kinder
flüchteten massenhaft in die USA wo sie
meist auf der Straße leben mussten
und von wem wurden sie dort aufgenommen
und sozialisiert genau von bereits in
den USA existierenden Banden als diese
neuen Maras aus den USA wieder in ihre
Heimatländer deportiert wurden waren sie
im Vergleich zu heute jedoch fast
harmlos mit der Zeit bildeten sie aber
verschiedene lokale Organisationen die
ihre Dienste sowohl den Regierungen als
auch dem Kartellen anboten und diese
nutzten sie dann um Angst in der
Bevölkerung zu führen so dass die Maras
zu regelrechten paramilitärischen
Gruppen heranwachsen die Mara
salvadrocia und das Barrio 18 sind die
beiden Hauptgruppen die sich wenig
verwunderlich häufig gegenseitig
bekämpfen und seit vielen Jahren
versuchen das salvatorianische
Territorium zu kontrollieren um ihre
illegalen Aktivitäten besser
organisieren zu können und es war eben
dieser Kampf um das Territorium der
unvorstellbaren Schmerzen und
unermessliches Leid in ganz el Salvator
verbreitet hat leider sind die
marabanten jedoch immer noch voll aktiv
wie kommt es also dass die Kriminalität
in den letzten Jahren trotzdem
zurückgegangen ist nun seht euch mal das
hier an
Drogenhändler nutzen Maras und
Straßenbanden um Zentralamerika zu
beherrschen ja dieses Bündnis könnte
paradoxerweise Grund für den Rückgang
der Mordfälle sein warum nun die Antwort
ist komplex aber um es ein wenig zu
vereinfachen könnte man sagen dass die
Maras als Zweigstellen der mächtigsten
mexikanischen Kapelle agieren wie zum
Beispiel des seniola kartens oder der
los setas interessanterweise könnte
dieses Bündnis dazu führen dass ein Teil
der durchgeführten Operation und
Machtstrukturen dieser Banken in weitere
Bereiche verlagert werden wodurch die
Aktivitäten der mexikanischen Kartelle
besser geschützt sind und dadurch von
der Straße wegkommen
lasst es uns mal so ausdrücken es gibt
lukrativere Geschäfte als den Laden an
der Ecke auszurauben aber das ist nicht
der einzig entscheidende Faktor
mexikanische Kartelle haben außerdem
bemerkt dass die Maras sehr effizient
sind wenn es darum geht Städte zu
kontrollieren und den größtmöglichen
Terror auszulösen deshalb rekrutieren
sie dort in den Mara Gebieten Truppen
für Mexiko selbst um Unterstützung für
ihre Aktivitäten zu erhalten und um die
eigenen Leute auszubilden auf diese
Weise haben die Mexikaner die Maras mit
ins Boot geholt und sie zu Akteuren des
internationalen Drogenhandels gemacht
aber wie genau helfen diese Banken den
mexikanischen Kartellen denn
offensichtlich dienen sie ja nicht dem
Wohl der Allgemeinheit
[Musik]
nun von den Maras lernen die
mexikanischen Kartelle die
schrecklichsten grausamsten und
skrupelloses Methoden um ihre Gegner
auszuschalten oder in Schach zu halten
Techniken die sie dann nach Mexiko
bringen und dort auch selbst anwenden
das ist also einer der eigentlich
traurigen Gründe warum die Kriminalität
in Zentralamerika selbst den
Herkunftsländer der Maras in den letzten
Jahren zurückgegangen ist es hat also
leider wenig mit den amtierenden
Regierungen oder den Plan der USA für
Zentralamerika zu tun sondern eher mit
der Eigendynamik der
kriminalitätindustrie welche
mittlerweile viel stärker geworden ist
als die Spaß macht und so selbst an mehr
Stabilität interessiert ist um ihre
Profite zu maximieren und sicherlich
denken jetzt viele dass die Sache dann
ja auch jederzeit wieder aus dem Ruder
laufen könnte nicht wahr Maras und
Kartelle die zusammenarbeiten er kaufte
Regierungen die von Kriminellen
Interessen gelenkt sind in effektiven
korrupte Sicherheitskräfte bestochene
Richter und so weiter ich meine was wenn
das Pendel wieder in die andere Richtung
schwenkt sich die Rahmenbedingungen
ändern und die Gesetze der
Profitmaximierung wieder nach mehr bald
verlangen glaubt ihr das Mittelamerika
überhaupt eine Chance hat diesen
Teufelskreis zu entkommen was können zum
Beispiel die Salvatorianer tun um nicht
mehr länger als das gefährlichste Land
der Welt zu gelten nun es scheint wohl
dass es sich hierbei um keine einfache
Aufgabe handelt
aber ein erster Umsprung könnte 2019
gelungen sein auf den politischen
Parkett trat ein neues Gesicht in
Erscheinung dass sich dem bisher
fehlenden politischen Willen
entgegensetzen und das Land in puncto
Sicherheit grundlegend verbessern will
ein außenseiterkandidat setzt sich bei
den Wahlen in El Salvador durch zu den
zentralen Versprechen des neuen
Präsidenten burkile zählte die
Sicherheit im Land zu verbessern und die
Korruption zu bekämpfen aber konnte er
sein Versprechen halten nur nach drei
Jahren Regierung lautet das Fazit zu
einem großen Teil ja den Präsidenten ist
es seit seinem Amtsantritt am 1 Juli
2019 gelungen die Mordraten deshalb
inspiriert von Guatemala eine
antikorruptionskommission ein boile hat
verschiedene Maßnahmen implementiert
unter anderem hatte auch eine stärkere
Präsenz des Militärs rigide Waffengewalt
seitens der Polizei und eine angeblich
harte Hand gegen bankmitglieder gesorgt
aber aufgepasst der Hauptgrund liegt
darin dass der Junge Politiker einen
Pakt mit den Banden des
landeseingegangen ist in dem z.B
verkürzte Gefängnisstrafen Geld für
Gangmitglieder und andere Vorteile
ausgehandelt wurden
[Musik]
ziel dieses Paktes war es bis zu den
Parlamentswahlen 2091 für Ruhe zu sorgen
und siehe da die Banken hielten sich an
ihr Versprechen und buchiles
parteikgewand die Wahlen Haus hoch mit
satter 2/3 Mehrheit wir haben über den
aufstiegburg kilist übrigens ein eigenes
Video gemacht dass ich euch hinter dem i
oben rechts und in der Beschreibung
verlinken werde auf jeden Fall nutzte el
Presidente die neu gewonnene macht um
seine Position weiter zu festigen und
scheinbar auch dazu den Spieß langsam
wieder umzudrehen
er will nun mal nicht das Schwänzchen
sein mit dem der Hund wedelt er will der
Hund sein und die Gangster zu seinem
Schwänzchen machen und dies scheint
bitte nötig zu sein denn er packt
zwischen Politik und kriminellen ist
sehr brüchig geworden im März diesen
Jahres kam es wieder zu Exzessen so
wurden in dem kleinen Land zeitweise
nicht nur über 60 Menschen an einem
einzigen Tag abgeschlachtet nein die
Maras machten deutlich dass ihr morgen
eine direkte Nachricht an die Politik
ist die Leiche eines ihrer Opfer wurde
auf eine neue gebauten Brücke in der
Hauptstadt abgeladen die ausgerechnet
eines von bouquilles Prestigeprojekten
ist das war ein klares Signal an den
Präsidenten und an die Touristen die
Gewalt wird genutzt um die Regierung
unter Druck zu setzen die Antwort des
Präsidenten ließ nicht lange auf sich
warten er spricht nicht nur Privilegien
für inhaftierte Gangmitglieder wie zum
Beispiel Freigang nein er griff gleich
zu harten gesamtgesellschaftlichen
Maßnahmen Maßnahmen welche die
Befürchtungen über seine wahren Ziele
nämlich den Aufbau eines autoritären
Regimes aufleben lassen der Präsident
Papst seine Zustimmung zum Einsatz
tödlicher Gewalt gegen die Maras und zu
einer Reihe harter Repressionsmaßnahmen
in den Gefängnissen des Landes in einem
Tweet forderte er das Parlament auf
sofort den nationalen Notstand
auszurufen der Kongress der von seiner
Regierungspartei dominiert wird
beschloss daraufhin einen 30-tägigen
Ausnahmezustand in den bestimmte von der
Verfassung garantierte Freiheiten
ausgesetzt worden die
Versammlungsfreiheit wurde aufgehoben
und die Polizei erhielt weitreichende
Befugnisse zur uneingeschränkten
Überwachung der Telekommunikation
aber was genau war eigentlich der
Auslöser für diese erneute Eskalation
nun die salvadorianische Zeitung El Faro
konnte die Hintergründe anhand geliebter
Tonaufnahmen aufklären gegen die
unbequeme Journalisten von Erfahrung ist
wo ihres Regierung übrigens schon öfter
repressiv vorgegangen wir haben davon in
besagten Video berichtet aber das nur am
Rand bemerkt denn nun dokumentierte El
Faro auf eindrückliche Weise wie sich
bokeles Leute mit bandenführern
unterhielten und eine Zusammenbruch der
Beziehungen Beklagten die Aufnahmen
enthüllten wie die Regierungsbeamten
über den Präsidenten lästern und als
Batman verspotten und auch die
Beziehungen zwischen dem designierten
Verhandlungsführer der Regierung und
einigen der bandführerschein eher
instabil zu sein sie enthüllten auch die
frühere enge Zusammenarbeit ein
hochrangiger vokille Beamter gab an
einen in den USA gesuchten bankenführer
persönlich aus dem Gefängnis geholt und
nach Guatemala gebracht zu haben der
capo befindet sich nicht mehr in
staatlichem Gewahrsam und hat es
Berichten zufolge bis nach Mexiko
geschafft gleichzeitig Beschuldigten die
Beamten
Mitgliedern sicheres gleich versprach
und sie dann trotzdem verhaftete der
Gewaltausbruch der Banken der sich nicht
nur gegen Rivalen sondern auch gegen
normale Menschen richtete war also vor
allem ihre wütende Antwort auf die
Machtdemonstrationen was ist also nun
das Fazit
[Musik]
nun fakt ist das ist okay ist seit
seinem Amtseintritt gelungen ist den
Abwärtstrend bei Tötungsdelikten
vorzusetzen und im Jahr 2021 einen neuen
Tiefstand von 17,6 pro 100.000 Einwohner
zu erreichen auf der anderen Seite kommt
deshalb war dort aber trotzdem nicht zur
Ruhe und es stellt sich die Frage ob du
Kehle die Konflikte mit den Gangs nicht
auch dazu nutzt um die Demokratie in
seinem Land Stück für Stück
auszuschalten mittlerweile wurde der
hochgradig umstrittene Ausnahmezustand
nämlich zum vierten Mal um einen
weiteren Monat verlängert 46.000
Menschen wurden seit Anfang März
verhaftet Menschenrechtler beklagen dass
die Maßnahmen die es der Polizei
erlauben Verdächtige ohne Haftbefehl
festzunehmen zu willkürlichen
verhaftungs- und Gewaltexzessen seitens
der Staatsmacht geführt haben viele
Menschen werden aufgrund ihres Aussehens
oder Ihres Wohnorts festgenommen so
wurden unter den Sonderregeln während
des Ausnahmezustands angeblich auch
Kinder verhaftet die keine Verbindung zu
Banken haben die für das kleine Land
riesige Zahl von Häftlingen würde unter
zum Teil unmenschlichen Bedingungen
gehalten und viele von ihnen würden
aufgrund mangelnder
Gesundheitsversorgung einfach sterben
ohne je ein Gerichtsverfahren zu
bekommen es handelt sich also um einen
sehr undurchsichtigen und brutalen Krieg
zwischen dem Staat und dem Maras und der
Blut soll es nach wie vor sehr hoch als
Zwischenfazit können wir also festhalten
dass rückläufige Mordraten teilweise auf
politische Akteure zurückzuführen sind
müsst häufig an der Dynamik der
kriminalitätsindustrie liegt ein
Bündnissen Interessen und so weiter die
ausschlaggebend sind so haben wir
gesehen dass es in Honduras heute nur
wenig Raum für Hoffnung gibt in El
Salvatore ist es zwar was die Morde
angeht früher geworden aber es gibt
keine Garantie dafür dass wo killes
riskanter und autoritärer Balanceakt
nicht mit einem ähnlichen Fiasko endet
wie sein bitcoin-abenteuer über welches
wir auch schon ein Video gedreht und
sein Ausgang leider richtig vorausgesagt
haben
[Musik]
denn wie beim Bitcoin scheint bouqueline
nicht wirklich daran interessiert zu
sein alle der Kriminalität in esservador
zugrunde liegenden strukturellen Gründe
anzugehen zwar prangert er ganz zurecht
die Politik der USA an welche zur Zeit
des Kalten Krieges die mörderischen
rechten hundas Lateinamerikas groß
gemacht hatte die auch in El Salvador
tausende von Zivilisten abschlachten
ließen und so die Gesellschaft
brutalisierten allerdings will er nicht
verstehen dass diese Zeit längst vorbei
ist und man die Vergangenheit nun mal
nicht ändern kann und die Gewalt so
lange weitergehen wird ob offen oder als
schwefelbrand so lange diese Länder
keine Strukturen für perspektivlose
junge Menschen unter Randgruppen
schaffen damit sie ein Leben führen
können das nicht von Kriminalität und
Gewalt geprägt ist um dieses Hightlight
Gleichgewicht von Kriminalität und macht
jedoch richtig beurteilen zu können
müssen wir noch ein weiteres
zentralamerikanisches Land mit
einbeziehen ein Land das nicht zum
nördlichen Dreieck gehört das aber in
letzter Zeit einen dramatischen Anstieg
von Gewalt erlebt hat allerdings
ganz andere Art von Gewalt der der
Drogenhandel ist nicht das einzige übel
das Zentralamerika plagt schnallt Euch
jetzt gegen Ende bitte noch mal gut an
denn nun nähern wir uns dem Höhepunkt
unserer zentralamerikanischen Reise
quasi der Auflösung der ganzen
Preisfrage also aufgepasst
[Musik]
Nicaragua das Ende eines Traums
Ihnen die carragua stoßen wir auf ein
Phänomen das in den meisten anderen
lateinamerikanischen Ländern in dieser
extremen Form nicht vorkommt nämlich die
Anwendung von Gewalt als eine Form
politischer Kontrolle
[Musik]
ja wir haben es in jedem Phänomen zu tun
mit ihm auch bokel-liebeutelt und es
handelt sich um ein ähnliches Szenario
wie in Venezuela das plötzlich mit dem
Mythos aufgeräumt hat Nicaragua sei eine
Ausnahme das einzige sichere Land in der
gefährlichsten Region der Welt ganz
genau Nicaragua scheint sowas wie
bokeles Vorbild zu sein so gab es in die
carragua beispielsweise 2017 nur 7
Mordfälle pro 100.000 Einwohner während
es in Honduras zur gleichen Zeit 40
waren in El Salvador 51 und den
Guatemala 28 der Unterschied ist also
bemerkenswert aber das ganze bedeutet
nicht dass eine caragua wirklich ein
sicherer Ort zum Leben ist es handelt
sich viel mehr um eine Warnung an all
jenen die glauben bouquelis Kurs sei der
einzig richtige die sandinistische
nationale Befreiungsfront die
Regierungspartei Nicaraguas ist bereits
dort angekommen wo bokelen noch hin will
sie hat den Staatsapparat Nicaraguas
vollständig durchdrungen und absolut
politisiert was ich damit meine nun
Gleichgesinnte wurden in allen
Schlüsselpositionen installiert und
echte paramilitärische Gruppen zu
Unterdrückung der Bevölkerung eingesetzt
der nicaraguayische Tyrann Daniel Ortega
hat buchstäblich damit begonnen
Schlägertrupp zu organisieren die Namen
der Polizei unter Armee schmutzigste
Geschäfte verrichtet haben und ja aus
politischer wie institutioneller Sicht
ist dies wohl eine der schlimmsten Kurse
die eine Führungspersönlichkeit
einschlagen kann
eine Welle bösartiger Verbrechen welche
die Unterschrift der Paramilitärs von
Daniel Ortega eine caragua tragen
beunruhigt die Region 2018 schossen die
Gewalttaten durch die brutale
Unterdrückung ziviler Demonstranten
durch das Regime von Präsident Daniel
Ortega in die Höhe denn sobald eine
Regierung damit beginnt die breite Masse
der Bevölkerung mit erregulärer Gewalt
zu unterdrücken schafft sie zugleich
Bedingungen die Gewalt legalisieren und
normalisieren Straffreiheit kommt an die
Tagesordnung und die Kriminalität nimmt
ihren Lauf das einzige was zählt ist nur
noch ist man für die Regierung oder
gegen sie die haben dies in Venezuela
gesehen und Nicaragua ist auf dem besten
Wege zu einer brutalen Diktatur zu
werden
Nicaraguas Regime hat nun im Juli 2022
die letzten Lokalregierungen in denen
noch Vertreter der Opposition saßen
gewaltsam übernommen über 200
Oppositionelle werden als politische
Gefängnis festgehalten ein Schritt der
Nicaragua näher denn je an eine
totalitäre Diktatur heranführt nur Tage
zuvor hatte Ortega rund 100
Nichtregierungsorganisationen aus
Nicaragua geworfen sogar die von der
verstorbenen Mutter Teresa gegründeten
Missionarinnen der Nächstenliebe damit
steigt die Zahl der verbotenen
zivilgesellschaftlichen Organisation
inklusive Medien auch über 1.000
[Musik]
Mitarbeiter von La brenza einer der
führenden Zeitungen des Landes waren
gezwungen aus dem Land zu fliehen
nachdem el Presidente und seine
Regierung weiterhin autoritär gegen
unabhängige Medien Vorgehen Ortega hat
nämlich seit dem Ausbruch der Proteste
gegen das Regime vor vier Jahren fast
alle zivilgesellschaftlichen und
caritativen Gruppen aus dem Land
verbannt er betrachtet sie als arme der
Opposition und der nicaraguanischen
Diaspora in Florida es geht natürlich
darum alle verbleibenden Kritiker des
Regimes zum Schweigen zu bringen und
zwar noch unbedingt vor den im November
stattfindenden Kommunalwahlen
schließlich hat der Ortega schon im
letzten Jahr vor dem
Präsidentschaftswahlen den führenden
potentiellen Oppositionskandidaten
wahrhaften lassen und das Hauptproblem
dabei ist Ortega kommt mit seinem Kurs
durch so das Beobachten andere
mittelamerikanischen Ländern sich nur
zunehmend Sorgen machen dass die
Unterdrückungsmaßnahmen in Nicaragua
andere Regierungen in der Region
ermutigen werden ebenfalls die
Daumenschrauben anzuziehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
letzten Monat verhaftete man zum
Beispiel in Guatemala den prominenten
Journalisten Jose Robin samura dessen
Zeitung sich auf korruptionsermittlung
spezialisiert hat unter anderem gegen
den derzeitigen Präsidenten Alejandro
giamatee interessanterweise folgte
samuras Verhaftung auf eine
Säuberungswelle unterrichten und
Staatsanwälten die sich auch auf
Korruptionsfälle von Mitgliedern der
Regierungspartei spezialisiert hatten
einige dieser korruptionsbekämpfer
wurden Geist Exil getrieben und wie
gesagt greift auch in El Salvador
Präsident naikukele regelmäßig nicht
Regierungsorganisation und Medien an
welche die Maßnahme seiner Regierung
kritisieren gleichzeitig sind seine
irregulären Verhaftungswellen ohne faire
Gerichtsverfahren zu Bekämpfung der
bankenkriminalität bei der Bevölkerung
sehr populär es könnte also leicht
passieren dass ukele die Situation
ausnutzt sich ein Scheibchen bei Ortega
abschneidet und beide seine Unsitten so
miteinander kombiniert dass eine Macht
zementiert wird Nicaragua könnte also zu
unrühmlichen Modell für die ganze Region
werden denn bemerkenswert ist vor allem
das und bouqueline aus unterschiedlichen
Teilen des ideologischen Spektrums
kommen beide viele Seiten aus Ortegas
Lehrbuch übernommen haben um ihre Macht
zu festigen wie er also seht sind in
Mittelamerika die autoritären macht
Ambitionen der Regierenden und die
Kriminalität Korruption und mangelnde
Sicherheit zwei Seiten ein und derselben
Medaille mexikanische Kartell und Maras
sind die eine Alternative brutale
Diktatoren die andere und in vielen
Fällen wenn auch nicht in allen arbeiten
sie auch gut miteinander zusammen
natürlich zum Leidwesen der normalen
Bevölkerung ich hoffe dass ihr nun über
einen besseren Durchblick verfügt was
genau in dieser Region der
gefährlichsten Region auf diesem
Planeten in puncto Gewalt vor sich geht
und auch versteht was ich hinter der in
den letzten Jahren rückläufigen Zahl an
Mordfällen verbirgt
[Musik]
und auch wenn euch dies alles wie eine
Folge Narkose oder eine Kampagne in
Tropico vorkommen mag für die Millionen
Menschen vor Ort ist es leider die
bittere Realität in der sie nach wie vor
sind es sei denn sie machen sich auf den
Norden Migration und Flucht aus diesen
Elend sind jedoch Themen für ein ganz
eigenes Video vergesst also bitte nicht
unseren Kanal zu abonnieren und auch
ganz wichtig das Glöckchen zu aktivieren
und keines unserer zukünftigen Videos
mehr zu verpassen und jetzt seid ihr
erstmal an der Reihe glaubt ihr dass
Sicherheit in Mittelamerika ein
unerfüllbarer Traum bleiben wird kann
sich die Region wirklich vom Fluch des
Drogenhandels oder organisierten
Kriminalität befreien begreifen die
Menschen dass die Zerstörung von
Freiheitsrechten alleine nicht die
Lösung der Sicherheitsprobleme sein kann
schreibt uns doch im Kommentarbereich
was eure Meinung dazu ist ich hoffe dass
euch dieses Video etwas gebracht hat
falls ja geht uns bitte ein Like und
teilt es auch fleißig mit euren Freunden
natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit
über eine Spende von euch mit uns hält
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen denn paper
Link dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]